JOE BIDEN, AND SO MUCH MORE,
ONLY MOMENTS AWAY.
TONIGHT THERE ARE 26 DAYS UNTIL
ELECTION DAY.
YOU WILL BE THE ULTIMATE JURY,
BUCKLE UP, BRACE YOURSELF.
THIS WILL BE A ROLLER COASTER
RIDE THE NEXT 26 DAYS.
DURING LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE,
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE WAS
UNFLAPPABLE AND HE NOT ONLY
EVISCERATED FRANKLY
SENATOR KAMALA HARRIS, BUT HE
EXPOSED JUST HOW RADICAL AND
FRANKLY DANGEROUS HER AND
JOE BIDEN’S POSITIONS TRULY ARE
TO THIS COUNTRY.
SHE ALSO GOT CAUGHT IN ONE LIE
AFTER ANOTHER.
HER RAMBLING, OR DISORGANIZED
ANSWERS AT TIMES WERE EVEN HARD
TO WATCH.
FRANKLY, IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE
SHE WAS EVER A PROSECUTOR GIVEN
HER UTTER LACK OF PREPARATION
AND TERRIBLE EXECUTION.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, BY THE WAY,
TODAY SENATOR HARRIS AND HER
FRAIL, WEAK RUNNING MATE, THE
EVER-FORGETFUL JOE BIDEN, THEY
STILL ARE FLAT OUT REFUSING TO
ANSWER SIGNIFICANT, SERIOUS
QUESTIONS, DOZENS OF THEM,
INCLUDING WHETHER OR NOT THEY
PLAN TO NEUTER THE UNITED STATES
SUPREME COURT WITH A CORRUPT
PRACTICE KNOWN AS COURT PACKING.
FRANKLY IT IS UNCONSCIONABLE
THAT THEY REFUSED TO TELL YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE TRUTH.
I GUESS THEY MUST THINK THAT WE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE REALLY
THAT STUPID.
THEY REALLY THINK THAT THEY CAN
JUST COAST TO THE FINISH LINE
WITHOUT BEING HONEST, WITHOUT
BEING TRANSPARENT, WITHOUT BEING
FORTHRIGHT.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA MOB,
STATE-RUN TV NEWS, STATE RUN
NEWSPAPERS, SO FAR THEY’VE
ALLOWED THEM TO GET AWAY WITH
ALL OF THIS, WHICH WOULD BE THE
BIGGEST POWER GRAB IN HISTORY
AND BY THE WAY, THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
THEIR NONANSWERS AS
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE SAID,
THAT’S THEIR ANSWER.
COMING UP, WE HAVE FULL
REACTION, DAN BONGINO,
KARL ROVE, CONGRESSMANAN
MATT GAETZ, THE GREAT ONE
MARK LEVIN WILL BE HERE WITH
THEIR FULL REACTION AND ANALYSIS
AND DON’T FORGET THE PRESIDENT
WILL JOIN US STRAIGHT AHEAD, BUT
FIRST, WE DO NEED TO TALK ABOUT
THE COMMISSION ON PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATES.
SUPPOSEDLY, NONPROFIT -- WELL,
SUPPOSEDLY NONPARTISAN AND
ORGANIZATION RESPONSIBLE FOR
CARRYING OUT THE PRESIDENTIAL
AND VICE PRESIDENT OF THE BAITS
BUT TODAY THE COMMISSION
UNILATERALLY, WITHOUT CONSULTING
EITHER CAMPAIGN, DECIDED TO
UPEND THE NEXT MATCHUP BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IF THEY WERE CITING THE
PRESIDENT’S COVID-19 DIAGNOSIS
AND THE COMMISSION ANNOUNCED
THAT THE DEBATE WOULD BE HELD
OUT VIRTUALLY OUT OF "SAFETY
CONCERNS."
THE PROBLEM IS, THAT WAS A
UNILATERAL DECISION.
THEY DID NOT CONSULT WITH THE
PRESIDENT’S DOCTORS.
THEY DIDN’T CONSULT WITH ANY
DOCTORS THAT WE KNOW OF OR THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF.
AND BY THE WAY, BY
OCTOBER THE 15TH, THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE MORE THAN 14 DAYS AWAY
FROM WHEN HE FIRST CONTRACTED
COVID-19, WHICH MEANS HE WILL NO
LONGER, ACCORDING TO OUR OWN
CDC, BE SHEDDING THE VIRUS, AND
WILL LIKELY HAVE IMMUNITY, AND
I’M SURE OUR DOCTORS WILL BE
CHECKING THAT OUT IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
SO WHAT’S REALLY GOING ON HERE?
ISN’T REALLY ABOUT COVID-19, OR
IS THIS DEBATE COMMISSION TRYING
TO BASICALLY HARNESS
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HELP
JOE BIDEN?
EARLIER TODAY, DONALD TRUMP JR.
TWEETED THE FOLLOWING.
"DOES ANYONE ELSE FIND IT
AWFULLY COINCIDENTAL THAT THE
MORNING AFTER PENCE DESTROYS
KAMALA HARRIS IN A DEBATE THAT
THE DEBATE COMMISSION
UNILATERALLY CHANGES THE FORMAT
TO OBVIOUSLY BENEFIT BASEMENT
BIDEN POST QUOTE?
KEEPING IN MIND DURING A VIRTUAL
FORMAT, THE MODERATORS, THEY
WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO A MUTE
BUTTON AND SLEEPY JOE WOULD HAVE
EASY ACCESS TO HIS TRUSTY
TELEPROMPTER.
SO TODAY DURING AN INTERVIEW
WITH OUR COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND
MARIA BARTIROMO, THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED HE WILL NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THIS VIRTUAL
DEBATE AND THIS LAST-MINUTE RULE
CHANGE.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT.
IT’S TIME THAT WE NOW ASK THE
IMPORTANT QUESTION HERE.
IF THE COMMISSION ON
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES IN THE TANK
FOR JOE BIDEN?
HAS THIS TURNED INTO AN
ANTI-TRUMP ORGANIZATION?
I THINK THE EVIDENCE AND THE
ANSWER IS SADLY ALL TOO OBVIOUS.
THE MODERATOR OF THE SECOND
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE, IF IT
HAPPENS, IS A GUY BY THE NAME OF
STEPHEN SCULLY.
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW HIM, MET HIM,
ACTUALLY LIKE HIM.
HE INTERNED FOR JOE BIDEN, HE
WORKED FOR SENATOR TED KENNEDY.
IT WAS NOT A FACTOR IN THE BAIT
COMMISSION’S MEANWHILE, LAST
NIGHT’S MODERATOR SUSAN PAGE CUR
SEEMINGLY GLOWING BIOGRAPHY OF
NANCY PELOSI ENTITLED
"MADAM SPEAKER: NANCY PELOSI AND
THE LESSONS OF POWER."
I GUESS IT’S NO SURPRISE THAT
SHE FAILED TO ASK SENATOR HARRIS
DOZENS OF IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
WHY?
I DON’T KNOW.
SHE DIDN’T ASK ABOUT LAW AND
ORDER AND SAFETY AND SECURITY
AND THE UNREST THAT WE’VE BEEN
WATCHING FOR THE ENTIRE SUMMER.
SHE DIDN’T ASK ABOUT
SENATOR HARRIS’ SUPPORT FOR THAT
BAIL FUND IN MINNEAPOLIS THAT
PUT VIOLENT RIDERS AND
ANARCHISTS BACK ON THE STREETS.
SHE DIDN’T ASK, WELL,
SENATOR HARRIS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
ALL ABOUT CALLING JOE BIDEN
PRETTY MUCH A RACIST ON A
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE STAGE.
SHE DIDN’T ASK ABOUT THE TIME
THAT HARRIS SAID SHE BELIEVED
BIDEN’S SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT THE ACCUSERS.
SHE DIDN’T ASK KAMALA HARRIS
ABOUT HER SMEAR OF
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
SHE DIDN’T ASK ABOUT ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER AND THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HE MADE
FROM FOREIGN COUNTRIES WHILE HIS
FATHER WAS THE VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE DIDN’T EVEN ASK ABOUT
PACKING THE COURTS.
IN FACT IT WAS VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE WHO BROUGHT UP ANY OF
THESE ISSUES AND WHEN HE DID,
SENATOR HARRIS JUST FLAT OUT
REFUSED TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
AND ALL-IMPORTANT POWER GRAB, A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE.
IT’S SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
TOUCHED IN OVER 150 YEARS AND HE
ASKED HER OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND STILL DIDN’T GET AN ANSWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JUDGE AMY CONEY BARRETT IS
CONFIRMED TO THE SUPREME COURT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
ARE YOU IN JOE BIDEN, IF SOMEHOW
YOU WIN BACK THE SELECTION,
GOING TO PACK THE SUPREME COURT
TO GET YOUR WAY?
>> JOE AND I ARE VERY CLEAR.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE VOTING
RIGHT NOW AND IT SHOULD BE THERE
DECISION ABOUT WHO WILL SERVE ON
THIS MOST IMPORTANT BODY FOR A
LIFETIME.
>> THANK YOU, SENATOR HARRIS.
>> PEOPLE, SUSAN, ARE VOTING
RIGHT NOW, THEY WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW IF YOU AND JOE BIDEN ARE
GOING TO PACK THE SUPREME COURT
IF YOU DON’T GET YOUR WAY IN
THIS NOMINATION.
>> LET’S TALK ABOUT PACKING.
COME ON.
>> YOU GIVE A NONANSWER,
JOE BIDEN GAVE A NONANSWER --
>> I’M TRYING TO ANSWER YOU NOW.
>> Sean: THE NONANSWER IS AN
ANSWER.
BY THE WAY, THIS JUST BREAKING,
THE AP IS REPORTING THE CHAIR OF
COMMISSION ON PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATES SAYS IT IS NOT GOING TO
RECONSIDER SHIFTING THE SECOND
DEBATE FROM VIRTUAL BACK TO IN
PERSON, DESPITE A REQUEST FROM
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM.
BY THE WAY, BACK TO HARRIS, SHE
NEVER ANSWER THE
VICE PRESIDENT’S QUESTION.
THE MODERATOR NEVER HELD HER
ACCOUNTABLE, DIDN’T EVEN FOLLOW
UP, SO IT SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE
THAT EARLIER TODAY, JOE BIDEN
ONCE AGAIN, HE REFUSED TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION.
HE DID SAY HE WILL GIVE US AN
ANSWER AFTER THE ELECTION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU WILL KNOW MY OPINION ON
COURT PACKING WHEN THE ELECTION
IS OVER.
I KNOW IT’S A GREAT QUESTION AND
I DON’T BLAME YOU FOR ASKING,
BUT YOU KNOW THE MOMENT I ANSWER
THAT QUESTION THE HEADLINE AND
EVERYONE OF YOUR PAPERS WILL BE
ABOUT THAT.
OTHER THAN -- OTHER THAN
FOCUSING ON WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW
NOW.
>> Sean: THIS IS A QUESTION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL MAGNITUDE.
YOU’RE SUPPOSED TO TELL US WHERE
YOU STAND ON THE POSITIONS TO
GARNER SUPPORT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
HIM NOT ANSWERING SHOULD SCARE
EVERY AMERICAN, AND LET ME LET
YOU IN ON A LITTLE SECRET,
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE WAS RIGHT
LAST NIGHT.
JOE AND KAMALA HARRIS HAVE
DECIDED THEY ARE GOING TO PACK
THE U.S. SUPREME COURT, AS
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID, EVERYTHING
IS ON THE TABLE.
NOW, IF THEY GET THEIR WAY AND
THEY INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
JUSTICES ON THE SUPREME COURT
AND THEY FILL IT WITH NEW
ACTIVIST JURISTS THAT BELIEVE
THEY CAN LEGISLATE FROM THE
BENCH, PEOPLE LIKE ELENA KAGAN
AND SONIA SOTOMAYOR ARE IN
JUSTICE BREYER, WELL, THAT WOULD
BE CORRUPT, IT WOULD BE ILLICIT,
IT WOULD BE AUTHORITARIAN, IT
WOULD BE A MANEUVER TO GIVE THE
DEMOCRATS TOTAL CONTROL OVER THE
COURTS AND THAT WHICH THEY
COULDN’T WIN AT THE BALLOT BOX
OR LEGISLATIVELY, IT WOULD
DESTROY COEQUAL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
THAT WOULD CEASE TO EXIST.
OUR AMERICAN SYSTEMS OF CHECKS
AND BALANCES WOULD BE COMPLETELY
EVISCERATED, MEDIA MOB, BY THE
WAY, IS ENABLING THEM TO GET
AWAY WITH NOT ANSWERING THIS
QUESTION.
WHAT ELSE DO THEY HAVE IN MIND?
DO THEY WANT TO END THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE?
WANT TO END THE LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER?
THEY WANT TO MAKE THIS PLACE OR
THAT PLACE OR D.C. ESTATE?
HOW MANY STATES DO THEY WANT TO
HAVE IN THE UNION?
THIS WOULD BE THE SINGLE BIGGEST
POWER GRAB IN THIS COUNTRY IN A
HUNDRED 50 YEARS AND IT WOULD
TRANSFORM THIS COUNTRY TO ITS
CORE IN A WAY THAT WOULD NOT BE
GOOD FOR EVERY AMERICAN AND
COULD VERY WELL DESTROY THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
IT IS A CLEAR AND PRESENT DANGER
AND THAT’S WHY JOE AND
KAMALA HARRIS ARE KEEPING IT A
SECRET.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE NOT STOPPING AT COURT
PACKING.
THEY LIKELY WANT TO END THE
LEGISLATIVE FILIBUSTER.
AGAIN, CHUCK SCHUMER,
EVERYTHING’S ON THE TABLE.
THEY WANT TO DITCH THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
ARE THEY READY AND WILLING TO
GIVE WASHINGTON, D.C.,
PUERTO RICO, STATEHOOD IN ORDER
TO ADD FOUR MORE GUARANTEED IN
THEIR MINDS DEMOCRATIC SENATORS,
IN THEIR VIEW A GUARANTEED
DEMOCRATIC MAJORITY IN THE U.S.
SENATE IN PERPETUITY?
DO THEY WANT ONE STATE PARTY
RULE, ZERO RIGHTS, ZERO INPUT
FOR THE MINORITY PARTY?
BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE.
IN THE MEDIA MOB, THE SO-CALLED
UNPARTISAN DEBATE MODERATORS
CAN’T EVEN BE BOTHERED TO ASK A
SINGLE QUESTION ABOUT SUCH A
HEAVY CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE AND
THE IMPACT IT WILL HAVE ON THIS
COUNTRY AND FUTURE GENERATIONS,
AND MEANWHILE THE TRULY UNHINGED
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI, SHE’S BUSY
FANTASIZING STILL ABOUT GETTING
RID OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SHE STILL HAS NOT ACCEPTED THE
RESULTS OF THE 2016 ELECTION AND
NOW SAYS WE ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE 25TH AMENDMENT, WHICH
LAYS OUT A PLAN OF SUCCESSION
SHOULD THE PRESIDENT BECOME
INCAPACITATED.
THIS IS WHERE HER HEAD IS AT,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
HERE?
TOMORROW, BY THE WAY, TOMORROW,
COME HERE TOMORROW.
WE ARE GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT
THE 25TH AMENDMENT.
BUT NOT TO TAKE ATTENTION AWAY
FROM THE SUBJECT WE HAVE NOW.
>> DO YOU THINK IT’S TIME TO
INVOKE THE 25TH AMENDMENT?
>> I WILL TALK TO ABOUT THAT
TOMORROW.
I WILL TALK TO ABOUT IT
I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT IT TODAY
BECAUSE AFTER TELL YOU -- IF YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT I WILL
SEE YOU TOMORROW.
>> Sean: COURT PACKING TODAY,
THE 25TH AMENDMENT TOMORROW.
WHAT ELSE IS ON THE LIST?
PRETTY MUCH A TYPICAL PELOSI
DAY, JUST LIKE THE LAST FOUR
YEARS.
AT THIS RADICAL EXTREME
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY CARE
ABOUT ONE THING ABOVE ALL ELSE,
AND THAT IS POWER.
POWER NOW OVER ALL BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT, POWER OVER RELIGION,
POWER OVER YOUR HEALTH CARE.
REMEMBER KAMALA HARRIS WON’T
EVEN ALLOW YOU TO GET PRIVATE
INSURANCE IF SHE HAS HER WAY.
POWER OVER YOUR BUSINESSES,
POWER OVER SCHOOLS, POWER OVER
YOUR RIGHTS.
IF POWER OVER EVERY ASPECT OF
OUR LIVES AND IN ORDER TO GET
THIS POWER, THEY ARE WILLING TO
LIE, DECEIVE, NOT BE TRANSPARENT
AND DO EVERYTHING AND ANYTHING
THEY CAN DO TO COVER UP THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT THEIR REAL
RADICAL AGENDA IS.
FOR EXAMPLE, HERE IS
SENATOR HARRIS BLATANTLY LYING
ABOUT JOE BIDEN’S PLAN TO RAISE
YOUR TAXES.
REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID.
I’M GOING TO REPEAL THE BUSH --
I’M SORRY, THE TRUMP TAX CUTS.
THAT MEANS ALL OF OUR TAXES WILL
BE RAISED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE SAYS HE’S SMART BECAUSE HE
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE TAX
CODE.
AND HE DOES TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE TAX CODE.
THAT’S WHY I’M GOING TO A LIMIT
THE TRUMP TAX CUTS AND I’M GOING
TO ILLUMINATE THOSE.
>> THE TRUTH AND THE FACT IS
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN VERY CLEAR,
HE WILL NOT RAISE TAXES ON
ANYBODY WHO MAKES LESS THAN
$400,000 A YEAR.
MR. VICE PRESIDENT, I’M
SPEAKING.
I’M SPEAKING.
>> THE IMPORTANT ISSUE IS THE
TRUTH.
JOE BIDEN HAS SAID TWICE IN THE
DEBATE LAST WEEK THAT HE’S GOING
TO REPEAL THE TRUMP TAX CUTS.
THAT WAS TAX CUTS THAT GAVE THE
AVERAGE WORKING FAMILY $2,000 IN
A TAX BREAK EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY --
>> Sean: EVERY AMERICAN THAT
GOT A TAX CUT ON THE
DONALD TRUMP WILL LOSE IT.
THAT MEANS THE TAXES WILL GO UP.
SENATOR HARRIS ALSO FLAT OUT
LYING ABOUT FRACKING AND WE’VE
GOT THE VIDEO EVIDENCE.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> I AM NOT BANNING FRACKING.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN.
I AM NOT BANNING FRACKING.
NO NEW FRACKING.
>> WOULD THERE BE ANY PLACE FOR
FOSSIL FUELS INCLUDING COAL AND
FRACKING IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION?
>> NO.
WE WOULD WORK IT OUT.
WE WOULD MAKE SURE IT’S
ELIMINATED AND NO MORE SUBSIDIES
FOR EITHER ONE OF THOSE.
>> SO FIRST OF ALL, I WILL
REPEAT, AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN WILL NOT BAN
FRACKING.
THAT IS A FACT.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO IMPLEMENT
IN A FEDERAL BAN ON FRACKING,
YOUR FIRST AN OFFICE, ADDING THE
UNITED STATES TO THE LIST OF
COUNTRIES WHO HAVE BANNED THIS
DEVASTATING PRACTICE?
>> THERE’S NO QUESTION I’M IN
FAVOR OF BANNING FRACKING.
>> Sean: NO MORE FRACKING, NO
MORE FRACKING, WE WILL ELIMINATE
FRACKING, BUT WE ARE NOT
ILLUMINATING FRACKING AND WHEN
ALL ELSE FAILS, DEMOCRATS, WELL,
THEY ALWAYS TURN TO MORALIZE
ABOUT RACE.
THAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT WITH
SENATOR HARRIS ONCE AGAIN
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT OF NEVER
CONDEMNING WHITE SUPREMACISTS,
FOLLOWING THE LEAD OF JOE BIDEN,
WHO’S BEEN MAKING THESE SAME
FALSE ALLEGATION.
THIS BY THE WAY AS -- JOE AND
KEMAL REPEAT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER
AGAIN AND THEY DON’T CARE THAT T
PROVING OTHERWISE, BUT TO HELP
EDUCATE THEM BOTH, WELL, WE HAVE
THE VIDEOTAPE.
>> HAVE YOU EVER HEARD THIS
PRESIDENT SAY ONE NEGATIVE THING
ABOUT WHAT’S A PREMISES?
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD IT?
>> I TOTALLY DISAVOW THE
KU KLUX KLAN.
I TOTALLY DISAVOW DAVID DUKE.
>> I GOT BACK IN HIS RACE
BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
PEOPLE COMING OUT OF THE WOODS
CARRYING TORCHES, THEIR VEINS
BULGING.
CLOSE YOUR EYES AND REMEMBER
WHAT YOU SAW.
AND THE YOUNG WOMAN GETS KILLED
RESISTING THE HATE AND VIOLENCE
AND THE PRESIDENT GETS ASKED TO
COMMENT ON IT, WHAT DOES HE SAY?
HE SAYS THERE ARE A VERY FINE ON
BOTH SIDES.
>> YOU HAVE SOME VERY BAD PEOPLE
IN THAT GROUP, BUT YOU ALSO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT WERE VERY FINE
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES, AND I’M
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE NEO-NAZIS
OR THE WHITE NATIONALISTS,
BECAUSE THEY SHOULD BE CONDEMNED
TOTALLY BURIED >> DAVID DUKE FOR
GOD SAKE.
>> I REJECT DAVID DUKE, REJECTED
DAVID DUKE.
I’VE REJECTED THE KKK, THE
KU KLUX KLAN FROM THE TIME I’M
FIVE YEARS OLD I REJECTED THEM.
>> Sean: 26 DAYS THAT THESE
LIARS IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
IF THEY DO WELL IN THE ELECTION
AND ARE ABLE TO CARRY OUT THEIR